[Music]
[Applause]
we spent a little bit of time yesterday
talking about Morgan Baron he plays for
the Winnipeg Jets and he took at least
75 stitches and then came back the next
period And I was wondering are you born
tough or do you become tough when you
become a hockey player and then I said
to fritzy why don't you see if we could
get Mark Messier on uh let's do over
under stitches that Mark has had in his
career
Todd I'll start with you has as Messier
had at least 75 total stitches yes I was
going to guess something in the
neighborhood of 93 93. Seton at one time
or total total I'm gonna go 175. 175
yeah Marvin I'm gonna go 123. Paulie I'm
going under 20. Mark gave out exactly he
gave out exactly exactly I'll say
Messier less than 25 stitches he joins
us now all right mess how many stitches
in your 20-year career
I would have zero idea how many but I
know it was more than uh
I know it was more than 20. okay I know
it was less than a thousand but
somewhere in between
what's the worst uh injury you got where
you had to get stitches
uh you know that's a great question I
was pretty lucky in a lot of uh aspects
uh from injury standpoint uh I never had
a cut where I had 75 stitches like Baron
did the other night that was uh pretty
pretty uh gutty for him to come back the
way he did but I I was more happy that
it was awfully close to his eye that
could have been a catastrophic injury
but uh he he definitely got lucky but do
they just Stitch you up on the table
they just take you in the back and just
start stitching right so they get the
old the old needles a little binder
twine that they put the hay bales
together and they saw you back together
and they throw you back out there anyway
but are you not numbing and numbing and
freezing is optional are you born tough
as a hockey player or do you become
tough as a husband well I think the
sport the sport makes you tough uh it's
uh it's it's a lot of pain to play
hockey it's certainly a lot of pain to
play winning hockey uh blocking shots
and sacrificing your body and all the
inherent risks that go out there
everybody thinks and it is hockey is an
amazing artistic ballet on Ice uh I I
often refer to it as more of a knife
fight say you got a 60-minute knife
fight with the you know 24 switchblades
of people skates traveling at 30 miles
an hour so the inherent dangers on the
ice are are there every day and it's
just a reminder when something happens
about it's just how dangerous the sport
it is and and how you know how how
incredibly tough and you know uh you
know how much resilience the players
have to play in that kind of tournament
for two months under that kind of
pressure but is your toughness different
than Wayne Gretzky's toughness
well that's that's that's a great
question you know Brian Leach was maybe
one of the toughest players I ever
played with and he never had a fight in
the National Hockey League uh uh but you
know as a smaller defenseman uh he never
once uh backed away from going into his
own Zone when he had the lakes of Larry
Eric Lindros you know coming bearing
down on him at full speed so there's
many different ways to to talk about
toughness in hockey it's just not
fighting it's it's a willingness to go
stand in the hard areas in front of the
net and take a pounding to score a goal
it's uh you know taking a check to get
the puck out of your own Zone and the
dying seconds uh you know so toughness
comes in many different forms in hockey
is is Wayne the best player of all time
uh well I I don't I think you might be
the best athlete of all time if you ask
me I'm a little biased because I got to
see pure genius for all the years I
played with him and against him uh his
numbers stack up that nobody can compare
us from a statistical standpoint so if
you want to talk about the best athlete
over the last century uh my my guess
would probably be Wayne Gretzky but I
wonder and the reason why I say this we
look at Michael Jordan and LeBron can't
surpass Michael Jordan in a lot of
people's minds it what would it take for
somebody to surpass Gretzky as the
greatest player of all time well it's
all subjective as you know because we
really are comparing you know uh
athletes from different eras and the
game has changed technology science
training I mean Everything's changed
athletes are getting bigger stronger but
what you can do is you can compare
different athletes of what they did to
their contemporaries when they played
the game and and if you just do that
statistically alone uh Wayne's number is
just outshine everybody's uh from what
he did uh to the competition so I'm not
sure how you can really judge it other
than people have their opinions and
certainly they have their favorites I
mean Michael Jordan was an easy guy to
like and the polls run was magical uh
even if you weren't a bulls fan you
couldn't take your eyes off it
compelling into the TV so
um but like I said I'm a little biased
with Wayne and because I got to see it
up close and personal
how do you think this season with Conor
McDavid is going to be viewed
historically
well I think you know he's emerging as
one of the best players to ever play the
game
um you know I think for what he did this
year in a new cap era uh with the new
rules uh the the the goaltending
becoming much better the defense is much
stronger
um you know I think there's so many
different ways that you can look at what
he did this year and how powerful of a
season individually it was
um and ultimately you know we're always
judged on whether you can actually win a
championship as a player and
statistically and what he's doing as an
individual is uh is is incredibly
impressive uh you know he's probably if
you look at all the other sports right
now is there anybody that's dominating
his sport as much as he is
uh from an individual standpoint but as
you know in a team sport it's all about
the Championships and your legacy yeah
sometimes you look at the greatness of a
player by who's next in line to that
great player and it feels like there's a
big separation there with well there is
a big Delta there this year and maybe
more so than any other sport does it
yeah yeah uh you know similarly with the
Boston Bruins I mean it's great to have
an unbelievable regular season but
Golden State Warriors won 73 games one
year they didn't win the championship
well it's hard to believe that uh the
Boston Bruins under the amount of parity
that's in the league right now uh with
the salary cap trying to keep a team
together for any number of years is so
difficult that they actually set a
record in the in the history of our game
with 65 wins this year it's incredible I
don't I don't really know if people
understand how
much of an amazing feat that was for
Boston this year especially early on
when nobody gave them the the the
respect that they ultimately deserve
because of the injuries that they had
and nobody penciled them into I think
everybody was thinking if they could
just hold on to 500 and then get healthy
and make the playoffs I didn't see it
coming I don't think anybody saw it
coming this magical Runner was just one
of the most impressive things I've seen
in our game in many many years
mess if I gave you the Bruins or the
field
that's a great uh that's that wow that
would be a great prop bet uh I uh see
now I even know the language
um I don't know
um
I would probably have to take the field
on that yeah there's just so many things
that can can go wrong the injuries so
many different things play a factor
and um
and every team has their weaknesses I
mean you don't see too many weaknesses
with Boston because of the year they had
and you're trying to figure out where
those weaknesses are but as we saw last
night Florida played hard
and uh sure enough they deserve to win
that game because of it and they did and
that's not an easy place to win in
Boston he's Mark Messier the Hall of
Famer when the Rangers won the Stanley
Cup I went to the party afterwards
and people were drinking out of the cup
uh and I I grabbed a sip out of the cup
I actually asked yeah can I just correct
you people were drinking a lot out of
the Stanley Cup I asked you what was in
the cup and you had some colorful
language as if to say if you don't want
to drink it then pass it to somebody
else and and I don't know what was in
that cup but I I just went I gotta take
a drink of the cup
and absolutely uh but just and just take
your chances what was in there
oh I I I think I I there could have been
a concoction that God only knows what
was in there but one of the craziest
things I ever saw in the Stanley Cup was
the world's largest remember in the old
days back in the 80s the the the the the
drink of choice was a B-52 I think it
was klua and
vodka and all this well they made the
largest B-52 in the Stanley Cup and uh
that was that was that was a shot of
choice that night but did you do any
like I know that when uh the Penguins
won I think it ended up at the bottom of
Lemieux pool or something like that like
did anybody any great stories with the
uh the Rangers Stanley Cup oh I I tell
you what if that Stanley Cup could talk
it could uh
that would be a best seller uh you know
I I think the Stanley Cup has been well
traveled and one of the things Dan as
you know that's it's probably the only
trophy that the players get to take and
parade around and take to their
hometowns and and really celebrate the
cup and it's probably one of the reasons
why it's such a people's uh trophy fee
everybody gets an opportunity normally
when someone wins it to take it to their
Hometown and get their picture taken
with it and the magic that it creates
and the the emotion that it that it
creates but you know it's done a lot of
good too you know not only the parties
but have done a lot of good with
Charities and many different uh things
and uh but as you know Dan we we did
have to get the cup of its own
babysitter after a certain amount of
events took place with the cup so I
think it's the only trophy of
professional sports that has its own 24
7 Babysitter Is there a player that you
played against you would like a piece of
you you still would like to hit him one
more time one more time
[Laughter]
it's not a place for pleasantries if
you're trying to win but when you played
against Gretzky having played with him
was there extra or incentive you weren't
allowed to probably hit him in in
practice some skate rounds no oh exactly
well of course I I saw people trying to
hit them all the years that I played
with them and then of course when he got
traded I really quickly realized that
my guess is I'm going to have to play
them hard when we do play and sure
enough the first year you got traded to
La when I was still in Edmonton we
played them in the playoffs and then I
realized how hard he is to capture and
to hit but uh back in those days uh
there was no taking any prisoners that I
if anything was in the way of trying to
win something as a good friend of Wayne
was uh and you know the greatest part
about it Dan too is that I think he he
knew that and he expected it so uh he
was he was pretty wildly on the ice and
he never got himself in a position to
get hit too often great to see you hope
you're having fun in TV and uh thanks
for joining us
great to be with you Dan take care
that's Mark Messier Stanley Cup playoffs
continue tonight on the mothership
starting at seven Eastern lightning and
the Leafs followed by Kraken Avalanche
at 9 30. Mark will be doing a studio
analysis for both of those games